she was the center of their world
they never imagined for a moment that
covert would end kelly's life
she was
an amazing wife
an amazing mother
and a a very loyal friend
having battled since december she died
last week
stephen vividly recalls the last time he
saw her in person
kelly went out to the ambulance probably
about 11 00 pm
that was the last time our words going
out the door was
i love you
unable to visit his mom dean posted
songs for her
she had rheumatoid arthritis but no
other underlying conditions
having watched your mom endure this
what would you say to people who believe
the virus is a hoax
and the restrictions are necessary
you're tempted to say you would
you wish they could experience it for a
day so they could see
just the effect it can have but i
wouldn't wish that on any of them
because it's just horrid i would say
that
the doctors at the end described what
happened to mom as
it had ravaged her body kelly was just
48 years old her husband and son
had to say goodbye to her on the phone
we
prayed with her told her we love her
talked about memories and stuff um and
then i read
psalm 46 tumor just as i finished the
passage
the doctor said that mum's heart had
stopped
so it would have been the last thing she
heard would have been
beast i knew that i'm god you give and
take away you
give and take away
no he sings in memory of his mom dean
says
she has gone home just not home to them
david blevins sky news in valemina